aussitôt déployé aussitôt loué plusieurs
stations se sont rapidement vidées de
leurs vélos en libre service
les montréalais avaient visiblement hâte
d'enfourcher leur bixi bixi en fait
pourquoi pas mal tous mes coups [ __ ]
travail l'été puis je pense est un moyen
facile de se déplacer je vais laisser
mon vélo pour les vols aussi c'est un
gros problème à montréal bixi c'est
vraiment pour me déplacer en ville c'est
facile ce économique sécuritaire et
clips et cyclables et tous ces parfaits
un peu plus de neuf mille vélos seront
déployés cette année avec l'ajout de 725
bixi électrique pour un total 2009 ça
c'est 20 % de la flotte qui sera
électrifiée c'est encore de la mobilité
active on n'est pas sur une mobylette on
pèse pas sur le gaz et le vélo à bouche
tout seul donc on maintient une espèce
de rythme qui vaut cependant être
constant que vous montiez une côte où
que vous en descendirent alors plus
question le des tranches horaires quand
vous allez arriver à votre rendez vous
où après avoir remonté le bémol le
réseau de bixi s'agrandit encore une
fois cette année six stations vont faire
leur apparition dans l'ouest de l'île à
pierrefonds roxboro et l'île bizard
sainte geneviève
les deux derniers arrondissement qui
n'était toujours pas desservis nouvelle
bien accueillie par vélo québec qui
pensent que bixi devra maintenant
s'attaquer aux quartiers défavorisés
je pense notamment à parc extension le
l'an dernier avait environ quatre
stations bixi pour un quartier de taille
similaire villeray qui à côté on était
plus autour de 25 ans fait la force
importante est de travailler sur
l'équité sur l'accessibilité du système
l'organisme a aussi revu sa grille
tarifaire l'abonnement de saison coûte
99 dollars le tarif mensuel a été réduit
de moitié à 19 dollars le tarif unique
pour un trajet de vélo électrique est
abolie il faudra maintenant payer 1 à
minutes savoir refléter essentiellement
tous les coûts supplémentaires liés à la
recharge des batteries ou répulsion
demandé vélo à l'entretien avec une
flotte et une emprise géographique qui
grandissent bixi espère atteindre record
de 6 millions de déplacements cette
année ici olivier vachon radio canada
montréal